the Arizona Republic reports that police
say a child's death in a hot car appears
to be accidental the one-year-old was
apparently forgotten for hours Saturday
while his father took a nap
this was arizona's second hot car death
in two days
nationwide eleven children died in hot
vehicles in the month of July it was the
deadliest month for children in five
years 29 have died this year Kris Van
Cleave shows us how new legislation
hopes to prevent more tragedy Chris good
morning good morning the newly proposed
law would require cars to be equipped
with sensors alerting drivers once the
car is turned off that a child is in the
backseat now some argue the technology
might not find its way to the parents
who need it the most but advocates say
the law is needed because the stakes are
just too high
I have not forgiven myself miles in
Carroll Harrison always wanted a child
they were overjoyed when they adopted
Chase but on a busy 90 degree day back
in 2008 Miles forgot to drop the 21
month old off at daycare leaving him in
the back seat of his car while he went
to work and it's heartbreaking because I
did it I killed my son nobody thinks it
will happen to them until it happens
Chase's death was one of more than 700
heat stroke fatalities of children left
in cars since 1998 an average of 37 per
year the first seven months of this year
have been the worst in terms of heat
related child car deaths since 2010
these tragedies can happen quickly when
it's around 90 degrees outside the
temperature inside a car will rise above
130 in less than an hour all cars ought
to include sensors that can very simply
save lives aiming to prevent these
tragedies Connecticut Senator Richard
Blumenthal introduced legislation
requiring car makers to install sensor
technology alerting drivers to a baby
left in a car seat consumers should want
this product just as they do seatbelts
and airbags
General Motors began offering a similar
sensor for some models this year but the
Alliance of Automobile Manufacturers
says the proposed mandate would miss the
car buyers who need it most
because so few parents of young children
buy new cars the Harrisons hope the law
goes through we need to stop families
having to deal with what I've done to
our family this law can do that senator
Blumenthal a Democrat believes any added
cost for the standard feature would be
minimal
he says the measure should attract
strong bipartisan support and hopes to
see it in new cars as soon as 2019 it is
a heartbreaking story and that took a
lot of bravery for that father to talk
to you like he did I don't know how you
would you would live with that it really
is just one of those awful awful things
he seems to be facing his own
accountability face-on is really good
reporting appreciate it